[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce dernier paf de l'année
2010 est donc l'année prochaine on vous
souhaiter une bonne année
mais parle pas encore parce que c'est
pas encore le moment mais on vous
souhaite commune de très belles fêtes et
pour préparer cette belle fête elle
vient il y as avec nous florence mercadé
bonsoir dans sa patrie l'avocate au
barreau de versailles et on est ravi
d'accueillir un autre un autre membre du
barreau vincent one escient vous êtes
avocat au barreau de paris
pénaliste
g et surtout ici en partie et on va le
voir vous avez vous préparé un livre sur
la liberté d'expression
qui paraîtra dans quelques mois et on va
peut-être parler de liberté d'expression
dans cette émission parce qu'il est dans
l'actualité des faits qui relever de
cette question
avec nous stéphane morceaux bonjour
autriche professeur à l'université de
versailles saint quentin est pas encore
en vacances jamais le travail commence
pour nous universitaires au moment où où
les autres sont en vacances des traces
et inversement et inversement voilà
mais voilà rien on en connaît qui est en
vacances
c'est ce nous en parle maintenant me
salue on le salut de tout coeur il n'est
pas volé voilà les anciens de la vanille
bonsoir bonsoir éditeurs toujours et
vous êtes tenus pas les mains vides je
puis dire puisque avec deux de livres
que vous pouviez des deux derniers opus
de votre maison d'édition sous pression
de pascal jaouen voilà ça c'est un livre
drôle écrit un peu en argot enfin une
langue très fleuri très verte en tout
cas
une enquête à novi sad police qu'elle
s'appelle bhl voilà bertrand hyllaire le
jeune mehdi bhl c'est très drôle et ça
se passe au havre donc
c'est de deuxième opus de ce pascal
jaouen chez nous c'est très marrant et
puis le plat de pâtes de didier faure vi
et un journaliste c'est son premier
polar et c'est un bon policier à ces
fameux et très original tout tourne
autour d'une interview que tout le monde
ici connaît très bien qui est le fameux
retable d'issenheim que tout le monde
navré de colmar et ça tourne autour de
ça donc c'est magnifique polar et art et
ergo de seigle en fait voilà mal et ça
bizarre god save voilà c'est mathieu
grade valdo exactement
savoir mais s'est écrié débarqué vers le
fond ça ne
s'est pas encore celle pas encore 2018
dont on arrive donc on va on va
peut-être parlé un petit peu des
événements qui nous ont marqués dans
l'année précédente juste une question de
vocabulaire parce que il paraît qu'on
dit plus maintenant les fêtes de noël
qu'il faut dire fêtes de fin d'année son
charme vous êtes très heureux de ça je
ne sais pas qui ne dit plus ça mais en
tout cas moi je dis toujours les fêtes
de noël et je crois que ça servirait
plus de la rumeur ça relève plus de la
rumeur est dû ce qu'on qualifierait de
gros fake que d'autres choses parce
qu'en fait tous les exemples que j'ai vu
c'est des trucs bidons en fait c'est la
laïcité quand même si important mais ça
n'a rien à voir ça n'a rien avoir à
faire à un petit peu
ne tombez pas dans tous les panneaux
conduite en jeu vive les crèches vive
noël mais les crèches partout il y aussi
de bien sûr il y en a toujours eu
des tueries des créateurs pour voir des
appareils 1800 commune à paris à paris
avant il y avait la plus grande crèche
du monde a quasiment et on
s'enorgueillit on s'enorgueillit c'est
de cette crèche magnifique voilà c'était
c'était bien ma peau pourquoi supprimer
les clashs ça c'est vraiment une
aberration enfin c'est donc dans la vie
politique et on est bien mais où on veut
où on veut des crèches on va promettre
une crèche dehors vous mais que ce soit
abriter j'attends que sap 1 cm pour
abriter
les intempéries absolue
en ce qui concerne à titre privé jeudi
déjà comme je veux oui donc vous savez
ça n'a rien à voir avec la laïcité donc
si moi je veux dire les fêtes de noël
jeudi les fêtes de noël etc c'est
d'ailleurs ce que je dis quand je
désigne noël c'est très précisément en
fait le 25 décembre non parce que pour
moi noël c'est ça c'est les cadeaux le
sapin en revanche si par exemple le
cabinet je demande ce que les gens vont
faire globalement
pour noël et jour de l'an voilà je vais
sortir effectivement comme sur les
fadettes pour les fêtes pour les fêtes
de fin d'année voilà mais quand je parle
de noël pour moi c'est vraiment les
clous 25 oui c'est le 24 au soir et 25
les cadeaux et leurs pas de danse un
seul vrai débat autour d'adolf c'est de
savoir se faire les cadeaux le 24 ou 25
4 le seul débat intéressant c'est tout
mais après c'est toi le 24 au soir moi
je suis plutôt pour le 24 au soir mais
après midi ba a priori
non une fois par an c'est bien
c'est plutôt le 25 non moi je m'oublie
noël ça me dérange pas du tout ce sont
deux ce sont de bons souvenirs les jeux
non mais je fait le solstice d'hiver oui
qui est antérieur fêtait déjà le
solstice d'hiver avant là avant la
chrétienté c'est vrai et j'aime bien
cette idée de fêter le solstice d'hiver
bah oui parce que les jours se
raccourcissent donc ils ont bien fait et
quelque chose et deux sur les jours
commencent à rallonger ranger à partager
à partir du solstice d'hiver voilà alors
si on parlait de la faire ton parce que
vivre
non mais si vous dites quoi alors moi je
dis quoi à titre privé dans les gens
avec les gens que je connais je dis
plutôt bonnes fêtes de noël à mes
clients je souhaite de bonnes fêtes de
fin d'année de façon globale parce que
je vais pas les revoir d'ici
probablement de janvier est pour moi le
souvenir
sur noël c'est le soulagement que j'ai
pu avoir quand j'étais petit de sorte
que le père noël n'existait pas parce
que j'attendais de cadeaux pour le 25 au
matin
oui enfin il n'existe pas selon que
selon certains mais pour d'autres
voilà on m'a dit que a fait croire qu'il
existait à prendre a fait croire qu'il
n'existait pas entre éjecté dans une
incertitude et je trouvais que cette
présence du père noël qui était un grand
bonhomme avec une grosse barbe était
moins impressionné beaucoup donc je
pense qu'on m'a dit qu'il n'existait pas
parce que j'étais angoissé sur le père
noël
nous n'était - coca-cola que vous donc
tous été saint nicolas
dans l'est voilà c'est mieux saint
nicolas et puis après c'est le petit
jésus le 24-25
297 contester les idées que ce soit
nicolas brochot quand même ils ont joué
à venir le 6 mai enfin bref le nouvel
album c'est nicolas c'est bien c'est
bien que si l'on avait dit s'est invité
à la conférence du stage non c'est
l'existence du père noël sap a fait
partie des débats ça aurait pu mais
disons que
vu le nombre de sujets plus ou moins
cocasses oui qui sont
distribués inventer chaque année
[Musique]
enfin j'ai pas eu à faire à celui des
non vous avez eu quoi bein donc j'ai eu
trois sujets le premier sujet c'est lé
coeur à prendre ce péché t-il à la ligne
et j'avais eu par l'affirmative le
deuxième sujet que j'avais eue c'était
les repas de famille sont-ils indigeste
abordant par la voix lascive aussi hélas
addictives on n'est pas forcément dû de
noël et puis le au troisième tour
j'avais eu les la peur inspire-t-elle
tous les crimes par la négative
et il faut qu'il faut expliquer parce
que les vagues tout bon mais pas le
connais parce que ce sont les
convergences du stage
ce sont des jeunes avocats
genou plus jouer en réseau de chaînes de
longs et idées on va dire dans le métier
oui qui
qu'ils passent un concours d'éloquence
entre guinée parce que bon l'éloquence
pourrait parler aussi de ce qu'est
d'éloquence mais sur des sujets loufoque
qui ne sont qu'un prétexte enfaite pour
certes écrire et servir sa propre
personnalité à travers un discours
et qui de ce fait sont un bon exercice
pour ce que pourrait être plus tard une
plaidoirie puisque une bonne plaidoirie
n'est pas forcément une belle plaidoirie
mais c'est une plaidoirie casse voilà
qui convainc pouvoir convainc minimum
est là
vous avez vu le film brille au soleil
sur les concours d'éloquence au
professeur de droit et professeur à
paris c'est pour ça que
oui qui fait semblant mais je n'ai pas
encore vu je vous dirais je
alors parlons de le faire trop parce
qu'il ya deux choses intéressantes dans
cette affaire c'est-à-dire l'oeil ou de
report du procès il faut dire que dans
envoyé spécial
il ya un témoignage
personne qui n'est pas encore témoigner
au procès
qui a dit avoir été agressée par par le
l'ancien député je croyais plus député
veille toujours maire maire de draveil
maire de travail
ce qui évidemment pose des problèmes je
pense pour la défense de l'accusé et
puis deuxième chose alors ayez ce report
du procès par ce qu'on appelle la
rupture de la fois du palais par maître
dupond-moretti c'est à dire de la
conversation en principe privé qu'il
peut exister entre les avocats et de
président
sur cette affaire oui justement qu'est
ce qui vous choque le plus c'est la
diffusion d'un témoignage ou c'est cette
rupture de ce qu'on appelle la fois du
palais où les deux hommes est aussi un
peu des deux faces surtout la diffusion
là je veux dire je suis extrêmement
perplexe qu'une chaîne publique puisse
diffuser un documentaire à charge
puisqu'il est exclusivement à charge la
semaine où il ya le procès en diffusant
des effectivement des déclarations d'un
témoin qui n'a pas encore été entendu
qui doit être entendu et ça je trouve ça
extrêmement choquant je trouve c'est une
responsabilité extrêmement importante ne
serait ce parce que dupont maury t il y
avait demandé le lendemain matin le
report du procès sur cet argument qu'il
n'avait pas eu oui puisque la
clandestinité elle aussi que valent à
l'ailé les auteurs du reportage disaient
qu'ils avaient demandé donner la parole
à la défense
de georges tron donc du coup mérite et
que celle ci avait refusé qu'elle aura
six pay plus que le roi mais pour autant
je trouve ça enfin bon je trouve ça
incroyable ce soit diffusé pendant le
procès qui le diffuse après au président
font ce qu'ils veulent mais pas pendant
le procès ou où les jurés doivent avoir
quand même un minimum de 20 de ne
pouvoir tirer leurs arguments leur
suspension c'est que voilà que
l'extérieur exactement que ce qui se
passe dans le procès et pas sur un
documentaire à charge à la télé donc ça
je trouve ça très choquant ensuite sur
la rupture
des discussions fait dans un bureau
fermé il ya deux points je pense qu'il
ya effectivement on a des relations des
fois sur des procès un peu quand il ya
des tensions où on peut se retrouver
dans le bureau fermé du juge avec le
parquet où l'avocat général des choses
se disent l'anah problème c'est qu'il y
avait des choses qui étaient très graves
qui ont été dites et nous parce par le
président de la cour d'assises notamment
sur la pression qu'il subissait et les
injures qu'il avait sur les réseaux
sociaux et le fait qu'il fait ne se
sentait plus enfin qu'il se sentait
personnellement ça serait mieux que ce
soit une femme à la barre des 10 de jeu
et ce serait bien que ce soit une femme
bon alors et peut-être subi aussi des
pressions de toute façon des réseaux
sociaux aussi et sur le fait qu'il ne
supportait pas d'avoir des hashtags
contre lui et que il le vivait mal et
qui se sentait perturbé et et
dans ce procès donc je comprends le fait
que
dupond moretti puisse après en tenir
compte en disant il n'est pas capable de
juger de manière objective parce que un
il considère que si ça avait été une
femme ce serait mieux et de deux il est
déstabilisé par les réseaux sociaux donc
ça pose un vrai problème dans la
conduite des débats donc ça je peux
comprendre qu'il puisse en faire part
mais en même temps
rompre la fois du palais et quand même
problématique puisque ça veut dire qu'on
n'aura plus cet espace de discussion qui
est de plus en plus réduits parce qu'on
a qualifié les magistrats des chambres
de plus en plus de mal à avoir des
discussions off entre guillemets avec
les magistrats et à pouvoir le parler
avec eux et là je pense que ça va être
ça va tendre les relations sur ce sujet
là je sais pas ce qu'en pense mon
confrère
métro alors je pense que d'être au
système de règles
et un équilibre à trouver
et un petit peu comme en matière
contractuelle ou le principe veut que
les parties cocontractantes
exécute de bonne foi leur accord
lorsque vous avez des principes il faut
qu' il y ait une loyauté si vous voulez
qu'ils soient partagées
dans la sphère
dupond-moretti entre guillemets puisque
en l'occurrence il n'était pas en plus
celui dans le dans le bureau du juge à
ce moment là c'était un de ses associés
antoine ev qui était là
le problème est que non seulement le
président a dit des choses qu'il
n'aurait pas dû dire
à cette occasion là
et notamment en plus de ce que vous avez
dit il a expliqué que certaines
questions il n'aurait pas posé certaines
questions il n'aurait pas osé poser des
questions que certains de ses assesseurs
ont posé ça fait beaucoup quand même
et lui même n'a pas tiré les
conséquences de sa et c'est là qu'il ya
aussi une rupture de loyauté dans le
procès pénal c'est à dire que pour faire
plus moins abscons vous avez un
président koré 6 qui vous explique
simplement qui n'est plus capable de
juger que le procès ne peut pas être
loyal que ya un problème gravissime et
c'est tout et le lendemain vous entendez
vous avez entendu ça d'ailleurs pas en
aparté pas simplement les avocats de la
défense mais tous les avocats tout le
monde était là je tiens à préciser parce
que très souvent ce qu'on appelle la
fois du palais ce sont des échanges
bilatéraux entre un avocat et le juge à
certains moments un qui n ont d d d un
espace si vous voulez qu'ils échappent
au contradictoire parce que justement ce
sont des échanges
et là c'était un petit peu différent je
veux pas dire que c'était un petit peu à
l'américaine où il savait comme quand
vous voyez dans les films avec les
partis qui demandent mais c'est un peu
ça donc il ya ces échanges n'obligeait
grier la personne tout le monde savait
terra quand même beau ensuite il un
grand principe de justice qui est comme
la manifestation de la vérité et c'est
donc on peut pas vouloir tout et son
contraire donc déjà est-ce qu'on était
dans le cadre de la fois du palais c'est
discutable et en plus c'est tellement
grave c'était tellement grave
mais c'était tellement grave si vous
voulez que comme le lendemain à
l'audience aucune conséquence on
attirait qu'est ce que vous faites
ouais je vais vous donner un dernier
exemple est peu près je laisserai la
parole ce que les avocats et pierre ans
- en particulier dénoncé à la meinau
parisé mais
sur le secret professionnel etc je sais
pas vous allez vous confesser vous allez
voir un prêtre vous allez vous confesser
que vous lui dites écoutez je peux que
je peux pas je vais assassiner demain
qui enfant et il habite là voilà je
tiens à vous le dire pour être pardonné
qu'est-ce qui fait le prêtre on va dire
avant il y avait violé le secret le
soleil conclusion que la confession ou
quelque part il va aller voir le
procureur voilà en espérant lui est
pardonné par par news ici là voilà c'est
tout donc je pense que dans ce cas là
voilà il faut prendre quand même ses
distances avec les imprécations et c'est
sur la rupture je moi personnellement je
pense pas qu'il y ait rupture ce que je
pense que c'était tellement grave ce qui
s'est passé que la défense n'a pas le
choix
juste une question de pour m'éclairer là
il ya un report du procès est ce que ça
veut dire que ça ne sera pas le même
président
mais en fait vous avez des
vous avez des sessions session d'assises
non non non non il n'y a plus d'accord
fera pas que ce soit les mêmes
assesseurs non plus
non et puis et puis vit de fait ce ne
seront pas non plus les à mesurer
ses frustrations une autre
chance à stephan ben non moi je suis
assez
convaincu parce que j'ai deux brillants
avocats nous ont dit oui enfin je suis
assez d'accord avec l'un comme avec
l'autre il ya un côté choquant parce
qu'en plus du pont mort et il est
peut-être un peu aussi en train de
toujours être dans la manifestation la
plus éclatante de son talent et ccc
systématiquement des sorties qui n'en
existe pas sur chaque point c'est des
presque en train de ce verger 6 et se
trouve donc
c'est un peu dommage mais je suppose
sinon monsieur bergé raconte avocat mais
c'est pas la distance de rupture non
mais
ce côté jeu à chaque fois que
j'interviens je vais essayer de créer
des mini scandale des trucs de toujours
interview intervenir il ya toujours une
bonne raison
a ses limites mais les magistrats
souvent les magistrats peuvent aussi
être impressionné par la personnalité de
certains avocats par la réputation de
certains avocats ça joue aussi gérer
surtout et les jurés et bien sûr une
grande cour d'assises âge je n'ai pas
plaider devant une cour d'assises et ça
n'arrivera probablement jamais mais
j'allais vous dire en fait on fait
autant de non droit que que de droit ah
ben oui j'en ai pas eu autant de
rhétorique et de psycho parfois de balma
lieu en
mai mais là ce cas est vraiment
intéressant parce qu'il ya une espèce de
course de conflit de loyauté enfin le la
loyauté qui devient un vrai principe de
droit de droit processuel vient il ya un
très bel ouvrage qui était écrit sur
cette question
enfin le loyauté au fond de deux des
avocats vis-à-vis du président loyauté
du président vis-à-vis à la fois de deux
des accusés et la défense et vis-à-vis
de lui-même sa fin le président aurait
pu ou aurait dû se déporter enfin je
mets mes le fonds vient de là il y
aurait peut-être pas eu de rupture de
7,2 cette fois du palais qui à mon avis
enfin je vois ça d'extérieur à une
importance capitale qui met de l'huile
dans les rouages qui sont permises et ça
parce que c'est important pour aborder
des avocats de torsades avoir des
conversations privées avec mais encore
une fois las le contexte est différent
vous savez il ya rien il ya un autre
exemple qu'on peut donner c'est que
secret professionnel entre avocats il
est absolu il est absolu juste jusqu'au
moment où il ne l'est plus comme comme
tout principe
vous avez notamment des exceptions
notables la première exception c'est
évidemment pour les besoins de sa propre
défense en tant qu'avocat n'est plus
tenu au secret si vous êtes vous même
mis en cause vous pouvez le rompre pour
vous les vents nouveau donné
que la voie qu'il ya rien il ya un autre
concept peut être un peu moins connus
des confrères mais qui existe en
déontologie c'est ce qu'on appelle la
butte confidentialité et notamment pour
éviter le mensonge par omission
vous êtes vous pouvez avoir un dans un
procès un confrère qui va soit dire
carrément des contre vérités dans ses
écritures dans ses arguments soient
omettre sciemment certains points
fondamentaux
alors que vous voulez ça l'est parce
qu'il vous les avez dit ou écrit et ça
c'est si vous voulez c'est une violation
des principes déontologiques c'est une
déloyauté en fait et donc du premier
loyer du premier de noyauter lazio
en fait vous ne pouvez pas sous le
couvert du secret mentir en fait
escroquer le
début
donc
voilà tous les grands principes même les
plus absolus vous en avez plein vous
avez la résistance à la loi injuste
voilà donc tous les principes doit être
appliqué strictement
sauf peut-être quand d'autres principes
supérieurs se commence à être en jeu est
à mon sens en tout cas si je devais
défendre
[Musique]
dupond-moretti d'annoncer dans cette
année là je sais ce que je dirais je
dirais que le principe supérieur
c'est-à-dire la justice en flèche ces
faits étaient été gravement atteints
c'est que mais d'une certaine manière
ils n'ont pas eu le choix et je dirais
une dernière chose le procès aussi qu'on
fait on leur fait dans ce cas là c'est
de
accessoirement de vouloir absolument
renvoyer le procès pardon mais en tout
état de cause même sans ce
set cet événement là s'ils veulent
renvoyer le procès pour quelques raisons
que ce soit c'est quand même leur droit
c'est partie de la stratégie de défense
a fortiori si on est dans un contexte
délétère où vous avez des réseaux
sociaux
ddd des reportages qui sont diffusés et
cetera c'est tout à fait leur droit
accessoirement oui mais là là évidemment
parce que derrière cette affaire trot et
galop ce faire la ferme stein bon et on
peut supposer quelques que la défense
des peut-être envie qu'on lui je sais
faire un petit peu plus tard dans un
climat qui sera peut-être plus apaisé on
sait pas s'il sera ou pas mais
l'histoire de la justice et les fêtes de
ça il convient de condamner à mort qui a
été condamné à mort parce que il ya vu
un crime terrible qui s'était qui
s'était comme y avait été commis au
moment de leur leur procès par exemple
16 noms s'est dit si l'histoire même de
la justice on peut pas remporter tout le
temps les procès parce qu'il ya pas ce
cas il
dans dans l'hers de la société il ya il
ya un climat qui est délétère et puis ou
kaki contre l'accusé direction des
réseaux sociaux avec tous les excès que
ça suppose il va vraiment falloir s'y
faire parce que là non on ne peut pas à
chaque fois se réfugie derrière ça ça va
être compliqué en tout cas je pense que
non il faut faire avec enfin vous
essayez de faire sans mais mais c'est
tout à fait dommageable soit le service
public qu'ils soient qui a été diffusé
cette séquence mais si c'était pas sur
service public ça aurait été sur nos
questions si je dois l'avouer qui s'est
passé
rappelons qu'il va falloir qu'il va
falloir s'habituer à ça donc je pense
que c'est que pour vous c'est des
nouvelles qui est très étrange c'est une
grand mère de que d'aider des
responsables éditoriaux fin des
rédacteurs en chef et laisser passer ça
parce que je suis jamais fait jusqu'à
présent fait on savait très bien pendant
un procès pouvait pas passer un
témoignage comme ça
sinon un autre le ferait un autre
d'après un autre canal un autre réseau
et que
ce serait dommage donc la justice
sereine
époque révolue cela étant dit il existe
quand même beaucoup d'interdiction dans
d'autres domaines par exemple en matière
électorale vous avez d un calendrier
électoral précis à partir d'un certain
moment il interdit de parler de diffuser
était à sa existe quand même c'est
arrivé par surprise la colas sarkozy
avait demandé d'ailleurs le repos
d'un documentaire sur lui oui avec on
était en période
république
n'ayant pas de frontières veut ce qu'il
va être interdite en france sera
diffusée depuis l'étranger est
consultable depuis la france comptait
bien sûr dans les gars du reun il ce
parfum en tout cas voilà ça existe et
ce qui est dommage c'est que dans notre
cher pays très souvent on soit obligé
pour résoudre les problèmes d'inventaire
et des interdictions je ne sais pas
faire autrement et donc là alors qu' on
pourrait se dire que surtout quand on
est journaliste que on est attaché à la
liberté d'expression et la loyauté au
contradictoire fin normalement
à l'objectivité frais etc etc sait on
peut regretter surtout que des
journalistes mêmes et l'idée on n'est
pas l'idée simplement en en conscience
de ceux s'empêcher de diffuser un
reportage comme ça en plein en plein
procès d'assises et ce procès c'est
surréaliste alors après jeunes y avait
treize autres
c'est très étonné des responsables ses
responsables sur ils savent quand même
ils ont encore un peu de métier enfin
sachant très bien que ça d'autres sont
virés pour moins que ça oui c'est
maintenant
c'est comme une sorte de faute
professionnelle voulez parler de ça de
suite
un mot quand même mais vous n'êtes pas
obligé de répondre parce que c'est votre
jugement après tomber
dupond moretti donne plutôt une bonne
image des avocats ou pas
jockey des autres bonjour ne poserait
pas mais c'est une image que j'aime bien
personnellement voilà de quelqu'un qui
n'a pas peur de l'affrontement
comme on est aussi wydad qui comme on
dit ah bon il fait quand même pas mal
d'envieux parce que en toute objectivité
lui reprocher plein de choses je sais
pas comment il se comporte avec les
confrères chez quelqu'un de gentil
d'agréable mais en tout état de cause
c'est un avocat brillant ouais qu'a
réussi
contrairement à vergèze
et peut-être que c'est pas le cas de
tous les avocats du
docteur
murray
s'était ces deux moments de la sphère
barbie et bien je crois c'est le montant
et le dessin
y'avait barbie guide et non seulement il
est cher mais on peut se dénuder titre
elle avait condamné et vite
mais bon
elle peut pas son index alors qui est
devenue maintenant le la figure de proue
de la liberté d'expression alors je
disais que vous allez publier avec b
très manuelle pirac est un des
spécialistes de ce sujet un gros livre
sur la liberté d'expression fait un
livre très en fait c'est un code ça
existe pas encore c'est la révélation de
compilation de textes et à livry les
jurys donné ces thématiques mans avec un
index important et c'est donc
ici c'est très intéressant alors je ne
vais pas lui évidemment puisque ce n'est
pas quand ça va jusqu'à un tout petit
peu le l'un des buts préface audit la
liberté d'expression au fond c'est pas
très bien ce que c'est
ça fait partie des six volets des
des droits fondamentaux dont en réalité
tout le monde sait ce que c'est qu'il
n'est pas défini c'est pas défini
spécifiquement monde et tant mieux d'une
certaine manière oui parce que si on
doit définir un élément de principe
alors pour moi sacré mais au sens voilà
c'est un principe supérieur supérieur
peut-être que c'est même la reine de
toutes les libertés quand on y réfléchit
et vraiment
donc une fois qu'on a dit ça
voilà il faut
il faut il faut veiller à son respect
alors on peut venir de maintenant les
dessus du cas de deux textes on pourra
rappeler pour sony enfin on en a
beaucoup parlé m'ont forme qu'il ya des
gens qui a poursuivi tex et un animateur
d'un jeu un peu france 2 qui s'appelle à
nos amours
et il était invité dans une émission
sur ses limites je crois en irak et y
raconte ne faut qu'une blague qui est
vraiment assez mauvaise
sur le
monde et sur les violences conjugales
les femmes battues évidemment pas la
meilleure période pour raconter ça et
france télévisions a décidé de le
licencier en gros c'est géré jbc
parfaitement résumé juste insisté sur le
fait que c'était pas
il se fait virer du service public pour
une blague pas très fine effectivement
sur une autre émission où il était
invité non pas en tant que salarié du
site us alors qu'on s'est fait tatouer
en dvd
il a une double casquette donc après
bien évidemment seul on peut dire que ça
tombe mal une blague sur les femmes
battues en ce moment et cetera mais si
on commence à trouver des moments pour
faire des blagues sur tel ou tel sujet
on fera bientôt plus de blagues du tout
cette façon c'est finalement ce qui est
en train d'arriver
la moitié des sketches de coluche sur
elles sont impossibles à passer
maintenant à une heure de grande écoute
tout ses blagues ne va pas les raconte
ici puisque sinon la télévision va être
mise à feu et à sang ici enfin des
blagues sur le les turcs par coluche je
fais des tonnes de blagues tous les
humoristes
voilà non mais ne serait-ce qu à chaque
fois il ne peut plus rien dire alors
qu'après
le président de france télévisions a
sûrement sur réagi après les
déclarations du président macron qui a
dit que je service public était la honte
de la france elle a dû se dit ah bon
voila il fait plutôt là qu'il faut que
j'ai sur réagi en longueur
oui
mais
c'est pas du tout ce que je veux dire
non mais macron ayant ayant critiqué ce
public elle s'est sentie vraiment
je laisse rien passer effectivement
marlène schiappa qui en rajoute une
couche enfin je veux dire delphine
ernotte dans son bureau devait se dire
voilà c'est une catastrophe vite été
nous alors ils ont profité de la
présence non mais dis patrie ça me fait
penser à des dossiers qui peut avoir au
cabinet où les employeurs ont un dossier
mais qui est pas hyper sécurisé où il ya
quand même des éléments pour d'autres
la part d'une chaîne de télévision de
virer un animateur qui est là depuis dix
huit ans dont l'émission fait un
véritable carton il va envoyer une
mission finale mais veut avec lui donc
les émissions et d elle gagne des parts
de marché quasiment chaque dimanche donc
c'est assez curieux ça c'est rare quand
il y aurait quelqu'un d'entre nous dans
ce cas oui mais enfin voilà ce que c'est
vraiment bizarre non la vraie question
alors c'est peut-être de savoir est ce
qu'on n'est pas en train de confondre la
réalité la fiction raconter une blague
c'est une c est une fiction c'est pas
c'est pas un comportement c'est pas du
harcèlement c'est pas du viol n'est pas
c'est pas des sais pas voilà c est qu à
cet inculte radio ça pourrait être une
critique des hommes et sa vague oui
d'après j'ai pas il faut des filles mais
je crois que dans son spectacle ici
raconte cette histoire pour se moquer
justement des hommes voilà c'est fait et
des hommes violents et non ils n'ont pas
notre accabler les femmes battues mais
au-delà de ça je veux dire est ce que
est ce qu'une blague c'est la réalité
non c'est une fiction est ce que ce
qu'on a le droit de censurer la fiction
voilà c'est ça le vrai question non
alors je sais j'ai bien sûr les idées
mais je vais mettre un petit peu les
pieds dans le plat
premièrement vous verrez qu'à chaque
fois qu'on parle de ce sujet et on la
fait encore ce soir la première chose
que chaque personne fait ses 10 rebonds
la blague est nuls ouais c'est vrai
premier point et ensuite on parle du
sujet donc moi je vais vous dire je sais
pas si la blague et nuls ou pas de suite
aux questions de deux importants mais ça
reste celle de la composante politique
c'est subjectif pour bien montrer que la
tension non non c'est pas de sujet ce
n'est pas de plus sur le sujet
d'ailleurs la blague peut faire rire
plein de gens là moi elle me fait rire
c'est un jeu voilà ce que je la prends
comme une blague évidemment jeu
ça c'est le premier pointage mais c'est
le point le plus important
c'est une blague alors à chaque fois que
l'on fait de l'humour il faut d'abord
dire attention c'est de l'humour donc ne
le prenez pas au premier degré vous
verrez d'ailleurs ça doit commencer même
dans certains spectacles si vous verrez
ça va arriver dans les spectacles
d'humoristes si certains passages choc
des personnes et sert à nous fasse faire
qu'on rentre dans un monde absolument
hallucinant donc en plus en l'espèce il
faut quand même savoir qu'ils prononcent
cela sert qu il est bien évident que si
vous aviez à un député l'assemblée
nationale qui a abandonné 7 élevé en
réaction à un propos et avait sorti
cette blague lavoyer peut-être que le
contexte il est vraiment différent là
vous avez quelqu'un qui est nourrice tu
de métier c'est son métier de faire des
blagues
il me semble que l'intention compte
quand même dans ce que l'on prononce
donc c'est un monsieur qui est humoriste
de métier qui sort une blague qui par
définition est fait pour choquer aller à
contre-courant etc et je vais même
rajouté pour terminer de mettre les
pieds dans le plat que c'est justement
parce que le contexte actuel qu'on parle
de weinstein ballon ce temps port et où
que ça vient l'idée de faire cette
blague là c'est justement pour ça et
quand il ya des attentats et bien
l'hebdo sort les la caricature de
mahomet justement et c'est donc c'est
dingue en fait donc on rentre à mon sens
dans un une
un processus là qui est d'une gravité
extrême voilà après savoir si la blague
aideront aussi tech c'est drôle on
général ou pas c'est pas le sujet vous
avez raison de le reprendre le dessus
j'aurais pas dû dire en effet que les
déchets vous avez
raison le dit presque par réflexe n'a
pas réfléchi après tout c'est le mourre
c'est subjectif enfin sackhoff fait ce
qu'il veut et je pense que vous avez dit
qu'elle est nulle parce qu'on est dans
le contexte weinstein moi je
ne peux pas dire que c'est l'histoire
qui efface le plus rire au monde
jeudi qu'elle n'était pas terrible parce
que elle est surtout très très bien je
me suis fait
j'adore des humoristes souvent au
spectacle et j'aime bien que les mairies
concernées à nouveau et là on dit bon je
pense qu'il a des raisons je pense qu'il
va que je sais pas s'il va contester son
licenciement pas mais il a caché ça je
suis là c'est un très bon avocat de
presse que j'ai compté donc il a quand
même des éléments pour contester son
licenciement dès lors qu'il est sur ces
huit en tant qu'humoriste et voilà il il
aurait
fait cette blague dans l'émission qu'il
anime sur leur vision est ce qu'on peut
pas dire cela c'est plutôt le special
one mais est-ce qu'on peut pas dire que
la procédure de licenciement qui porte
atteinte à l'image
qui est qui et qui est celle de sow 2 e
1000 et 2000 emplois oui mais là il est
en tant qu'humoriste est déconnecté de
son métier
fauteuils delà de son contrat de travail
sur france télévisions il l'aurait fait
c'est pour ça il l'aurait fait sur la
chaîne publique
dans le cadre de son émission gp32
s'appelle la les amours
peut-être que là il portait atteinte à
l'image de son employeur de ce qui a été
payé pour ça on ne l'a sûrement droit
social
bien pire dans l'émission
le point positif c'est que des
humoristes de deux week de les horizons
il ya quelques humoristes parler de
desproges à la gauche il ya quelque
chose du maurice qui a très sympa sur
une chaîne de radio de service public
qui le tire à boulet rouge sur lui le
seul fait que je trouve assez peu
confraternel est assez peu intelligent
mais bon les noms des gens comme
stéphane guillon est là mais si on fait
ça dépend des galaxies à part cette
petite bande de de france inter soit la
doubler les ai entendus a plutôt de
soutenir aussi dans une émission non
mais bon cela dit cette source entre 17h
et 18h
c'était des gauchistes serra ils sont
tellement dans le politiquement correct
et dans l'évidence dans le
nez ça parce que
c'est parfois très drôles et l'ehpad il
était pas déguisant jeunes ont été
décaissés
globe-trotter en blanc
on a un truc de fiction bon donc séparé
l'intention la quelle est l'intention
derrière tout le monde s'accorde tout le
monde sait pertinemment qu'il y avait
pas d'intention mais on fait quand même
le procès donc ça s'appellerait ça
s'appelle vraiment un procès d'intention
et aujourd'hui on ne fait que ça on ne
fait que ça en réalité on utilise au
siam ans le ce qu'on appelait autrefois
le politiquement correct pour essayer de
voilà faire passer certaines idées à
travers votre livre devrait paraître et
certaines expressions n'existe pas point
n'existe plus
ce que vous dites est juste patrie c'est
à dire que dans sa dans un système
libéral libéral au sens de près de 2 789
le régime juridique français le contenu
d'une liberté n'est pas a priori
déterminée et donc ont peu ce qu'on peut
prendre la question par tous les bouts
vous ne s'annulent nul n'est capable
sauf à être un véritable imposteur mais
c'est pas évidemment votre cas de
définir ce que c'est que la liberté
d'expression puisque dès lors que
j'évoque la question de liberté je ne
parle dans un régime libéral que d'une
seule chose je ne parle que des limites
le champ des libertés c'est le fait de
savoir quels sont les metal acceptable
et quel système de garantie je mets en
place pour que ces limites ne soient pas
excessivement attentatoires aux libertés
mais liberté ne sont pas sont pas
définies a priori le contenu d'une
liberté il est vide et sept arrières
matin elles sont programmées directement
bien sûr et c'est à chacun de remplir ce
vide et on le voit toutes les questions
qu'on se pose est ce que il avait le
droit par le droit serbe a priori il
avait le droit ensuite au droit de dire
s'il a ou non dépassé les limites de ce
que je crois qu'il ne les a pas dépasser
enfin devant les juridictions du travail
je ne sais pas mais enfin devant sur un
contentieux ce type là par exemple
devant la cour européenne des droits de
l'homme est évident que oui ils
l'emportent sans sans aucune difficulté
donc auprès des prud'hommes je ne sais
pas dans la cour d'appel je pense qu'ils
n'en veulent en voir devant les
juridictions françaises c'est d'ailleurs
garavan fait même de fonder un
licenciement et dessus parce que quelque
part ça le signal qui a envoyé ses il
n'avait pas le droit c'est une faute
l'avalanche pour les licenciés probable
si ce qui y'a tellement là en réalité
ces voix là non le l'essentiel parce que
il a commis une faute or il n'a commis
aucune a priori d'un mois sauf preuve du
contraire la centrale contre ce qu'on
disait c'était peut-être contre le bon
goût mais ça c'est totalement subjectif
de la morale
des sièges arrière et on parlait aussi
tout à l'heure vous évoquiez la question
de 2,2 la liberté d'expression de la
part des élus la part ou bien est-ce que
si ça avait été prononcé à l'assemblée
de stars alors c'est vrai que les a
priori enfin pas tous mais les élus sont
un peu plus peut-être plus attentifs
parce que leurs préoccupations c'est se
faire réélire essentiellement donc c'est
déjà une maîtrise peut-être un peu mieux
la langue de bois mais mais surtout là
aussi il ya essai et c'est heureux notre
système juridique est le système
européen confère une protection très
forte à la liberté d'expression des élus
beaucoup plus forte que vous avez les
avocats les universitaires les
journalistes et les élus qui sont quatre
catégories qui bénéficient d'une
protection particulière d'une protection
spécifique infime de leur liberté
d'expression dans les bateaux les
avocats lié au débat politique les voilà
à la nécessité de pouvoir c'est le
travers très largement la controverse
politique doit se régler politiquement
et pas par le droit et pas juridiquement
donc à la limite soyons fous sisi texte
avait été député il aurait pu je crois
aussi
prononcé voilà cette histoire on a le
droit de faire au cours d'une séance de
nuit aurait-il été réélu jean sérien
du pire
des insultes d'insultés oui les insultes
qui se sont parfois régler en duel entre
elles
cette question de faire en 67 et là ça
aurait de l'alluré
plutôt que de saisir le juge mesiano
justement puisqu'on est sur la liberté
d'expression la le gallimard
pense republier les pamphlets
antisémites de céline
et là aussi ça fait ça fait passer une
vie histoire ça parce que lucette
descaves vous ne voulez pas qu'ils
soient publiés maintenant j'ai la 105
ans comme quoi elle serait plutôt
d'accord c'est vrai que là aussi un cdu
est ce que il faut encore interdire d d
d d écrits sachant que si on est un peu
malin on peut se les procurer
c'est facilement aujourd'hui mais mais
est ce que l'interdiction des cris vous
semble quelque chose de
combat envisagé aujourd'hui a
encore une fois
l'important me semble-t-il c'est là
l'intention des personnes en fait
si
par exemple ce qui complique de ceux qui
écrivent de ce qu'ils y
font la publicité et s'était réveillé
tard si je suis une association à
connotation raciste
un peu connus thérapie que je à oui
d'accord j'ai dit je leur ai dit on
pourra peut-être légitimement penser que
il n'a rien penser
si je suis un éditeur qui est dit toute
l'oeuvre de céline qui décident depuis
je sais pas quand et qui décide cette
reddition l'a déjà
lâché
même si elle-même le sujet avec mein
kampf voilà si vous êtes historien vous
avez comment vide qui m ont donné un
bouquin pour pouvoir mais c'est quand
même oui c'est quand même intéressant
c'était votre sa chance y avait trop de
enfin quoique non vu ce qui se passe
dans mon jeu les derniers plus trop de
jeunesses hitlériennes viendra justement
et si vous les avez raison ça peut être
utilisé si vous voulez tout peut être
utilisé tout propos s'est infligée par
historia par griezmann en disant à notre
hauteur ben vous allez avoir des gens
qui vont dire qu'il est raciste que ces
blacks fait c'était je crois qu'il a
découvert lui même ceux de ce terme
ouais on peut toujours tout faire dire
n'importe quoi n'importe qui voilà donc
ce qui compte c'est l'intention
et puis d'ailleurs pour le coup et même
de pierre on a beaucoup parlé oui par
les commentaires ce sujet n'a sur les
redditions c'est effectivement ce qu'il
jugeait mal et ça parce qu'on est petit
nom de ce qu'aurait pu faire le saut en
hauteur ce qu'est ce qu'il y ait une
identité entre l'oeuvre et puis l'auteur
mais est ce que parce que justement
beaucoup de livres il ya aussi sur le
sexe il ya aussi sur un vrai sur
beaucoup de sujets qui ont été censurés
sur la censure 20 est-ce que questions
difficiles exposé l'impression qu'il ya
plus de sens eu aujourd'hui 2
notamment dole dans les publications
dans les livres ou pas nous notons
censure
s'en serait probablement de beaucoup de
directeurs de journaux comme d'éditeurs
comme 2 toute personne qui peut délivrer
une certaine
connaissance ou c'est un certain type
d'information effectivement une trouille
colossal de tout le monde si si je
publie ça je vais perdre la moitié de la
population si je publie ça je vais
perdre telle subvention si je publie
s'assume est mal avec telle communauté
enfin voila c est cet appui le mont
terri pas parce que la censure fait
partie aussi de l'histoire de la
littérature et de oui mais
on peut estimer qu'ils y allaient bien
aujourd'hui l'histoire iver moines
censure que vers plus de sensibiliser
relisez comme on dit la thèse de jack le
détail le tertre
une forme d'histoires juridique delà de
la censure qui fait partie de
l'engagement de toutes les activités
culturelles artistiques et
oui c'était avant avant son arrivée à
danser oui donc après si les choses
peuvent le provoquer des débats tant
mieux c'est très bien ça on peut parler
des choses on peut en discuter rendez
compte de flaubert c'est le parfait
voilà flaubert a été victime objets
d'art de varier d'une procédure la
sortie de mauvais
mais j'ai l'impression week-end
peut-être moins de deux procès
judiciaire si je peux dire que deux
procès deux
médiatique enfin de buzz comme on dit
et qui empêche les choses enfin du coup
mes captures des conséquences ce presque
aussi terrible que l'interdiction
judiciaire tout démarre de façon
ridicule je vais
peut-être pas grand-chose à voir ou au
départ mais la déclaration de la
dernière miss france qui juste avant
d'être irrégulière dit voilà pourquoi
pas moi il y avait une brune y avait une
blonde y en a une liste avec une
crinière de lionne pourquoi pas une
rousse ça a été hachée n'est mêlé les
passions les gens ont parlé de race est
tombé sur la tête enfin une crinière de
lionne heures que jones était la
dernière miss france qui était visée
votre look les huits à la ddt
mais aux lions
de manque de culture inhérents vidéo
la mode c'est une expression très connu
et qui vraiment un compliment me crie
comme nous posez les raisons parce que
personne n'a relevé la ville et
radiologiques c'est fini mais tout à
fait il ya eu des
très bien on la compare à une
c'est tous les jours tous les jours ces
détails de cette
profite fait d'avoir des juristes autour
de la table et un éditeur parce que ça
ferait un bon bouquin
aussi match
pour sais pas si vous avez vu cette
affaire de criminels qui a été confondu
27 frais de créer un produit qui a été
acquitté pour ce crime là alors il se
trouve que le type il est en prison pour
d'autres crimes qu'il a commis mais
s'ils ont aussi aussi on si on théorise
un peu l'histoire 1
quelqu'un qui est acquitté et dont l'adn
montre qu'il est le criminel une
juridiquement il ne peut pas être rejugé
puisque quelques et écouter ne peut pas
être jugé mais est ce que ce principe
juste eu mans de l'acquittement qui
profite la personne qui a été accusée
tient encore avec
les progrès scientifiques qui permettent
maintenant de savoir à coup sûr si
quelqu'un est au camp nou pa jusqu'à
présent au pouvoir en doute il y avait
des éléments mais à dix gros il a été
acquitté et peut-être certains peuvent
pour ses clips pas vous n'avez pas de
certitudes là on a une certitude c'est
un beau sujet je trouve deux romans tête
mais
il est légalement innocent et
scientifiquement coupable ray
et il faut alors penser qu'il faut pas
revenir sur ce
révision ne fonctionne que dans l'autre
sens il est condamné à la perçois quand
elle était innocent
oui et saufs aujourd'hui on peut voir
comme ça mieux vaut 1
coupable en liberté ému des innocents
mais mais mais là en fait je je je
j'essaie de vous dire tout ce que je
sais patrice voilà j'aurai j'ai mes
mains sur le buzzer voyez l'idée
j'entends bien l'idée que comme ça il
peut y avoir un coupable dans tout le
monde sait qu'il est coupable en liberté
ce que disait tu rentres laissera pas le
seul est ce que ça ne remet pas en cause
ce principe justement que la quitte pour
profiter un accusé
ils profitent pas l'accusé dont
bénéficient les a quittés il a quitté
oui mais
l'expression profiter salut nous c'est
le mot qui me vient alors à moi ça me ça
me fait penser à quelque chose qui me
tient pas mal à coeur c'est le concept
d'innocence à titre personnel je suis
opposée alors je vais ferrures et tout
le monde mais pas la présomption
d'innocence et à ce concept de
présomption d'innocence est en fait
c'est le terme innocence moi qui me vrai
niveau chardy qui me choque je sais pas
d'où ça vient ça doit être un héritage
judéo-chrétien je ne sais quoi pour moi
ça n'a rien avoir à faire ça ne devrait
rien avoir à faire en fait dans la dans
le système judiciaire c'est écrit c'est
dans le code pénal
favori y est présente mais non voilà
c'est à dire que est d'ailleurs leurs
titres cadeaux vu tu as repris
d'ailleurs et d'ailleurs aucun tribunal
aucune juridiction pénale ne prononce
l'innocence de calvino nord button mais
c'est important et c'est très rare donc
en fait on est juste à coupable mais
comme d'ailleurs d'ailleurs d'ailleurs
je laisse ça à votre perspicacité mais
vous avez en amont la présomption
d'innocence et en aval soit la
culpabilité soit la non culpabilité il
n'ya plus matinaux sans se connaître
c'est important et vous avez raison
parce que quand
souvent fin des jeux qui sont
poursuivies se pavanent désormais la
présomption d'innocence on a
l'impression qu'ils ont et innocent
mais c'est enfin c'est un autre site du
raïs et rien de plus
oui ça veut dire que ça il appartient à
l'accusation d' de faire la preuve c'est
simplement un principe procédurale et on
lui fait chanter le blues
est important mais c'est rodez où il
n'était pas neutre du tout il est trop
fait et donc aujourd'hui les galvauder
puisque dans tout le monde oui
présomption d'innocence y compris sur
les plateaux de télé ou en ce moment
alors il est présumé innocent c'est à
mourir comme on a dit bon à la blague
nuls hop ça c'est fait et puis après on
d'abord de sujets là on y va mais en
fait non c'est ça ça va pas donc moi je
suis pas tellement en tant qu'avocat
pourtant farouchement a farouchement
attachée à
la défense mais vivent les droits de la
défense et à bâle
vive l'accès au dossier vive le
contradictoire ville est vrai que cette
présomption d'innocence moi je préfère
que mon client soit présumé coupable dès
le départ et avoir le secret de
l'instruction l'accès aux dossiers
complets le contradictoire la loyauté
des débats
peu compliqué
je sais mais c'est un vrai coin mais
pourtant c'est un vrai point
c'était quelque chose dont on parle et
et la présomption mais quand vous êtes
acquitté au bénéfice du doute risques ça
veut dire ça veut dire que avec le
système judiciaire que l'on a comme vous
l'avez justement rappelé dans lequel
l'accusation doit prouver la culpabilité
quand elle ne peut pas le faire avait on
dit on s'arrête là bon et vous laisser
la personne vivre et on passe à autre
chose on dit pas elle est innocente
c'est tout alors évidemment pour les
parties civiles puisqu'il faut aussi
bien pesées s'ébroue une victime c'est
que c'est une personne qui est reconnue
comme victime donc s'il ya un
acquittement la victime de quelqu'un
d'autre en nuances
mais tous ces concepts sont à manier
avec précaution mais ça peut être
effectivement difficile pour des
victimes ou des parties civiles d'avoir
un un acquittement pur pour défaut de
preuve voilà mais que faire
calé quelques faire dire écoutez alors
par eux
par des faux bond n'a pas trop de
d'éléments mal et on va pas laisser des
gens dans le doute on enferme les gens
mais ça vous fait rigoler quand on me
dit comme ça mais en fait appliquer ce
principe là à chaque cas d'espèce
considéré et vous verrez c'est pas si
simple que ça
alors il nous reste à peu près trois
minutes donc peu de temps et alors il y
avait des sujets comme notre dame des
landes comme ont peut-être qu'on
pourrait revenir quand même rapidement
sur 2017 si je voudrais le fait que vous
retenez de l'année en dehors d'un tueur
présidentielle en dehors du pape aussi
qu'ils revenaient chaque année enfin se
tenir en échec une boutade
une plaisanterie privé grâce à ses
qualités de l'année de l'année le fait
qu'il vous a marqué en 2017 ce n'est pas
de l'art élection présidentielle
l'arrivée de neymar et de maps et au psg
très bien gagner beaucoup d'argent et
beaucoup de bons joueurs donc enfin à
plein de titres c'est une information
intéressante et que je retiens et
stéphane s'est abonnée à toutes les
scènes de football à
suivre l'islande
dès 2017 écouter pour moi une très bonne
année pour les huîtres de ma région
qui était
de l'oléron marraine etc oui qui a été
malade ah oui mais voilà il ya de beaux
coups pas dire là dessus au point qu'on
va chercher des naissains au japon pour
essayer de repeupler etc mais 2010 est
un très bon cru pour les huîtres
on n'a pas assez dit et on a passé la
presse mais on va
défier vous parce que c'est bientôt fini
le cru 2010 800 peut-être pas aussi bien
vincent warin escient
aurait coûté
je ne sais pas je dirais qu'en tant
qu'avocat ce qui m'a pas mal frappé
c'est la sphère fillon en fait oui le
processus justement par rapport à la
présomption d'innocence le
contradictoire ce qu'ils disent sur les
plateaux télé le fait que maintenant
d'environ n'en parle plus maintenant
c'est vrai ce qu'il est essama en dehors
du festi gay serait pas les deux encore
aller vite encore une fois peu importe
je sais pas ce dont je la parle de ce
qui s'est mal si c'est bien s'il est
coupable ou pas mais la manière dont ça
a été ça a été traitée et surtout le
l'impact que ça eu pour la première fois
c'est à dire que concrètement envie de
dire le les médias en général en général
on fait l'élection une certaine manière
c'est c'est quelque chose qui m'a marqué
en tout cas fait c'est vrai ça me
renverse bonne première aïe
non ce qui me réjouit c'est le sait le
renouvellement du personnel politique
d'avoir d'autres têtes
plus jeune avec d'autres idées j'espère
qu'elles prendront pas de travers
de l'ancienne politique et puis à devoir
l'explosion des partis politiques ce qui
m'intéresse c'est ce qui va se réécrire
est de partir sur des pages blanches et
d écrire autre chose vous est confiante
pour 2018 bon bah j'espère bien ouais
c'est quand même plutôt
politiquement oui
avec général pas tellement ce je pense
pas que de la société savante d'acapulco
en résumé
chercheuse certaines choses dit pas non
mais ça risque d'être pire
et bien sûr nous c'est une question dont
nous
débattrons des ballerines après les
fêtes après les fêtes de fin d'année
c'est du banc après noël
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup france
peyrecave et merci beaucoup vincent
gestion et vous revenez quand vous
m'avez vous voulez je reviendrai dégoût
vitré le plaisir merci vous postez pas
dans son bain c'est beaucoup de
recherches de nîmes fatah à tous et on
se retrouve si vous voulez bien bas
l'année prochaine
[Musique]